okay
um welcome everyone uh and thank you for
joining us this evening
for a presentation and discussion of an
academic
paper safe seats and female
under-representation
in the u.s congress by akil
rajan alexander kustov
mikel serda francis rosenbluth and ian
shapiro
this event is part of a series of events
that isps the institution for social and
policy studies
is holding this year called isps
democracy
and these events bring together experts
from yale
and beyond to shed light on key
questions concerning american politics
governance and democracy
the next event in this isps democracy
series
will be tuesday april 13th
at 4 pm our regular time is 7 but this
is at 4 pm
rethinking political representation
where we'll have a number of experts
on novel ways of holding elections
and engaging in legislative
deliberations
um before i continue on to discuss
tonight's event i want to make sure to
thank the organizers of this event
pam greene lamonica tori bilsky
and lemour peer so here are the
logistics
for tonight's event we'll have the
authors present their work for about 20
minutes
after that we'll have about 10 minutes
each
from two discussants that we've invited
to this event and then after the
discussants
um conclude the panelists will have an
opportunity
paper presenters will have an
opportunity to respond to the
discussants
after which we'll have some time for
questions from the audience
and here's how the audience will ask
questions uh please save your questions
till after the discussants have
concluded their
remarks and use the raise hand button
on the bottom of the zoom screen to
indicate that you have a question you'd
like to
ask also if you'd like you can send
questions
to the panelists via the chat
and if you do that um through the chat
um keep the questions reasonably concise
so that they can be read and
understood easily and i just also want
to indicate that tonight's event is
is being recorded with that let me
introduce
tonight's participants first the
presenting authors
in shapiro is the sterling professor
of political science at yale university
he served as chair of political science
from 19 1999 now that's
i think that that's i bet longer than
that you've served as chair of political
science for a number of years very
successful and wonderful years
and you also served as the director of
the macmillan center for international
and area studies
from 2004 to 2019
in as a fellow of the american academy
of arts and sciences the american
philosophical society
and the national academy of social
insurance he has written widely and
influentially
on democracy justice and methods of
social inquiry
his current research concerns the
relations between democracy
and the distribution of income our
second presenter is akil
rajan rajan is a senior at yale
univer at yale college enrolled in the
simultaneous
ba m a program in political science
and the multidisciplinary academic
program in human rights
rajan studies the intersection of
political behavior and populism
as well as policy responses to the
threat of democratic backsliding
he was an isps director's fellow in 2019
and a doll scholar during the 2018-2019
academic year alex kustov
is a postdoctoral associate in the
leitner program on effective democratic
governance
in the jackson institute for global
affairs
his research focuses on public policy
responses to immigration
and ethnic conflict in high-income
countries
he received his phd in politics and
social policy from princeton
and will be an assistant professor of
political science and political
administration
at the university of north carolina at
charlotte uh starting in august of 2020
and i do want to recognize the
non-presenting authors
uh who are not going to be making a
presentation tonight but contributed
very much to the paper uh francis
rosenbluth
is the damon wells professor of
political science at yale
a fellow of the american academy of arts
and sciences
a um
a leading scholar of comparative
political economy
um and a beloved colleague
her current work focuses on the
electoral micro foundations
of different forms of capitalism on the
politics of gender inequality
she published many articles on on a
variety of subjects
some recently on the political economy
of gender and on women's
underrepresentation in politics
a recent book with ian shapiro was
responsible parties
saving democracy from itself published
in 2018
and then the fifth author on this paper
is make ulcerta
uh certain is a postdoctoral fellow at
yale university
received a phd in economics from nyu
cerritos research interests include
industrial organization
competition policy statistical learning
and applied microeconomics
so those are our paper authors uh
i'll finally conclude with our two
discussants our two discussions are
francis lee and jonathan rodden francis
lee
is a professor of politics and public
affairs
and associate chair at the department of
politics
at princeton university fellow of the
american academy of arts and sciences
her research centers on american
politics
with a special focus on congressional
politics
national policy making party politics
and representation
she is the editor of the cambridge
elements series in american politics
and her recent book insecure majorities
congress and the perpetual campaign
explored the rise of congressional party
conflict
showing how shifts in competitiveness
had a profound impact on how democrats
and republicans interact in the policy
sphere
lee is the recipient of the highest
prizes for her scholarship
in america and from the american
political science association
she received the richard fenno prize for
the best book
in legislative studies and she is a
two-time recipient
of the db hardman prize presented by the
lyndon baines johnson foundation for the
best book
on the u.s congress from the fields of
biography
history journalism and political science
i'll just say that
there's no one who is a finer scholar
of the contemporary congress who's
actively writing now than
than professor lee it is a true delight
to have her with us tonight um jonathan
robin
jonathan rodden is a professor of
political science at stanford university
he is a senior fellow at the hoover
institution and the stanford institute
for economic policy research he is the
founder and director of the stanford
spatial social science lab
the center for research and teaching
focuses on focusing on geospatial
analysis in the social sciences that's
the subject that jonathan is
is among the world's experts on that
subject the geo
geospatial analysis of of politics
rodden's interests lie at the
intersection of political science public
economics and geography
he's the author of a number of books
including a 2007 book
hamilton's paradox the promise
and peril of fiscal federalism and he
for which he was the recipient
of the gregory luberd prize for the best
book
in comparative politics in that year um
again
thank you jonathan welcome back to yale
jonathan
was a uh a student here a number of
years ago
and it's it's wonderful to have you back
so with that
um let me turn it over to i believe ian
is going to go first
um let me turn it over to ian after
ian and uh and uh akil
and alexander are done we'll go
immediately to francis
and then jonathan the panelists will
have their discussion
and then they will you will go
immediately to question and answer
uh thank you all for joining us this
evening
uh thank you alan uh and thank you
pam and more for doing all the the
heavy lifting to get us here this
evening thank you also to francis and
jonathan
for agreeing to do this we very much
appreciate it and we look forward to
your comments
um i'm just going to talk briefly about
the
project out of which this paper came and
then i will turn it over to
um akil and then alex
to present different parts of this
particular paper
um as alan mentioned this work comes out
of the
lightner program on effective
demographic democratic governance
at the jackson institute that francis
rosenbluth and i
uh run and we should take note that all
of the research
here is uh paid for by jim leitner
through that program and we wouldn't be
able to do it
but for his generosity the
the remit if of the
of the program is to study which types
of democracy are
most conducive to good public policy and
within democratic systems as we find
them as we've inherited them if you like
what institutional reforms would would
make them
operate more effectively and produce
better public policy
this is the work uh that uh this one
stream of this work
that alex michael akiel and i have been
doing with francis
that has produced several papers and is
producing
several more and they've all focused in
one way or another
on the
organization and governance of political
parties and how that affects political
outcomes
um in the u.s this has led us to uh
to devote a lot of attention to the
study and
of the operation and evolution of the
primary system of course at the
presidential level that's only been
since the 1970s when they became
important but at the congressional
levels
as everyone knows primaries have been
around since the progressive era
so it's not just primaries that have
gotten our attention but rather the
interaction between
primaries and safe seats
and we built up a data set on the growth
of safe seats
that they're going to be talking about
tonight
and so uh we've been looking at that
more generally as it relates to things
like party discipline and the capacity
to produce policies that are good for
the economy in the longer run
this particular research comes after the
intersection between that
and francis rosenbluth's ongoing
interest in female representation
and so that was bringing those two
streams of
of interests together that have resulted
in the paper that
that we're going to talk about tonight
so with that let me turn it
over to akil uh the floor is yours
great uh thank you professor shapiro let
me just load those slides up
uh so thanks everyone for coming out
today so as professor shapiro was saying
uh we're going to be looking at the
problem of
the rise of safe seats in the united
states and how that's going to help us
understand this growing phenomenon of
women's underrepresentation in the us
congress
but before i dive into that i want to
start with a brief road map for where
we're going to go in our presentation
today
so i'm going to start by talking a
little bit about the problem and the
conventional
explanations for this gender gap between
the parties
and women's representation in congress
then
we're gonna shift over to talking about
our story contrary to these conventional
explanations that safe seats are to
blame
uh alex is gonna hop on and talk about
the connection between safe seats and
extremism
and then we're gonna loop back to this
question of safe seats and women's
representation
we'll have a little bit of a discussion
and questions for further scholarly
inquiry and then we're excited to get
some feedback from our wonderful
discussants here today so to just ground
us in the idea of the problem
uh it's well documented across political
science and also across popular media
that women are dramatically
underrepresented in the united states
congress
but what is sometimes less appreciated
is the trajectory of
how things are changing within the
democratic party we are seeing
substantial
gains for women politicians especially
the house of representatives
slightly less your gains in the senate
but among republicans we're actually
seeing very anemic growth and one way to
look at that is in the partisan gap
in women members of the u.s house so if
you go all the way back to
1985 to the 99th congress there was no
partisan gap there was an equal number
of women and men
uh sorry of women elected from the
democratic and the republican party
versus today you see a huge gap of
upwards of 60 seats between the two of
them
most famously we saw this in 2018 which
was heralded as the year of the woman
for the record number of women who were
elected to congress but
actually if you look at the closer at
the data a record number of republican
women
lost their seats so when we're talking
about this gender gap in representation
it's also important that we look at the
growing partisan gender gap as one of
the sources
now the conventional explanations are
twofold first
some point to the partisan gender cap
among the electorate it's true that we
see these same patterns
uh reflected in the electorate women are
more likely to vote for democrats and
men
on average are more likely to vote for
republicans and the second explanation
is of course the under supply of
republican women candidates which is
someone
what related to that first explanation
but there are a couple reasons why we
think both of those explanations fall
a little bit short so the first looking
at the partisan gap in the electorate
we see that it's always been high dating
back to 1980 you had almost a nine point
gender gap
and today if you're looking at exit
polls in presidential voting which as
unreliable they are offer us probably
the best metric for inter-temporal
comparison
that gap has risen to about 11 points so
it is true that you could argue that the
gender gap has gotten wider
but perhaps not as significantly among
the electorate as it has among elected
representatives in congress
so to put that more concretely the
gender gap since 1985 in congress has
uh risen from zero to 60 seats between
the parties
among the electorate it's increased by a
maximum of about four points
and the other thing to note is that in
contrast to our last slide which showed
this
steady rise in the gender gap between
the democrats and republicans
in congress the swings in the electorate
haven't had
either the drama in terms of magnitude
but also direction
we saw times in this period between 1980
and 2016 when
most scholarly accounts would agree
actually the gender gap among the
electorate
got less severe and yet the gender gap
among members of congress has
increased steadily the second
explanation would be that under supply
story that there just
aren't enough women republicans running
but there are two problems with this
the first is that an under supply story
itself
is arguably endogenous you can't
construct a complete causal story and
the reason
is something we'll get to later in our
presentation which is if you say that
there are voter biases
against women candidates and women
candidates don't run
because they're aware of those voter
biases can you really say the under
supply
is the complete causal story for why we
have women's underrepresentation
we think that that's a flawed argument
or at best an incomplete argument
and then the other reason that we are
are skeptical of this conventional
account is that it's unclear why this
problem of undersupply
should have increased in magnitude over
the past years despite the fact that
candidate access to the ballot has been
greatly democratized over the years we
see more candidates running
and therefore we should see arguably
lessened gender barriers to candidacy as
well
so for those two reasons we enter this
project skeptical of the conventional
narratives around uh the
gender cap within congress
so our story uh is focused on the
electoral institutions that create these
uh gender biases in representation and
specifically safe seats
so we see the partisan gap as a function
of declining electoral competition
we provide evidence and we hypothesize
initially that women candidates are
going to outperform men in democratic
safe seats but crucially they're going
to underperform men in republican safe
seats
and we'd say that because of that the
recent rise in safe seats the
exponential growth of safe seats among
both parties
can help contribute to that explanation
of why this partisan gap has grown
over the period of time we're studying
um
the prior literature really builds to
that hypothesis
in three separate ways so the first is
there's a wide body of evidence about
how women candidates are stereotyped as
more liberal than men
that goes back into the 1990s but with
more recent
additions like sanbon matsu and dolan in
2009
seems to be a pattern that is still well
and alive
we also see some evidence in the
literature that safe seats are
intensifying the importance of primaries
and thereby
extremism because the primary mode of
competition is no longer this general
election
where uh politicians are supposedly
competing for the median voter
but rather the primary where they're
competing for the median primary voter
and we're also going to present some
evidence in addition to this prior
literature
for why we think that effect holds and
why we think these safe seats encourage
extremism
and then the final thing we are going to
talk about uh
is a combination of both a literature on
how safe seats have been on the rise
over the past decade
and also a new data set we put together
to document precisely
how much they have risen over this
period of time
so with that i'm going to turn it over
to alex to preview
our our arguments about safe seats and
extremism
yeah hi everyone thanks akil uh so i
just wanted to kind of elaborate on this
last two points that you had about the
importance of safe sheets
and their increase and this is a part of
our broader project
on you know the role of electoral
competition and
party governance but i think it's very
relevant to today's papers also i just
wanted to spend a few minutes on that
um so um
first uh you know i just want to kind of
present this very kind of basic graph
which plots
you know the ideology of a certain
representative alongside their
uh you know the partisan composition of
their constituency
and you know this graph basically shows
that
in places with more democrats you have
more liberal
representatives in terms of the voting
patterns and in places with more
uh you know republicans you have
representatives who vote more
conservatively quote unquote as measured
by dina bully nominate score which of
course we know
has certain limitations but well we can
also show that this picture is pretty
much stays
uh staying the same regardless of what
major use whether it's cf scores dw you
know it's
course or some kind of interest group
scores and you know oftentimes when you
see this picture
i think the first thing that pops up
which we fully acknowledge is that
you know if you take a given district
with a certain composition let's say
a district with a you know more or less
even partisan composition of democrats
republicans you know depending on
whether it's represented by a democratic
republican the
dw nominee score the ideology of
representative and their voting patterns
can be very
different and it's true but what we also
see here is that
you know it is also true that depending
on the partisan composition of a certain
distinction whether it's a safe
democratic seats or a save the
republican seats the voting patterns of
representatives are very
much different you know we don't want to
kind of have any normative
ideas about whether it's bad or good but
i think it's also important to have some
kind of
comparative lens and think about whether
it's
truly need to be the case so for
instance if we kind of consider
not just the us but kind of other you
know two-party
democracies then we can also see that
actually this doesn't have to be the
case that
you know a place with a more uh you know
like a safer constituency for insurance
party it has to have a very different
voting patterns you know if the party
has control over
candidates and you know kind of
institutions are different
so why is it the case that you know safe
receipts
produce more extreme candidates so there
are three main reasons for that that
you know kind of we want to emphasize
the you know first most obviously is
that you know obviously if you have a
very
safe democratic seats that probably it
is the case that on average
uh you know it has more extreme
democratic voters and so
the you know the representatives are
kind of responsible
uh respond uh responding to these more
extreme voters
uh it is actually more um
convoluted the story than you might
think and for instance you know jonathan
101 over
discussions has a very good evidence on
that that you can
easily imagine that you can have a
majority
democratic district that mostly voted
for biden but it's actually not that
extreme in terms of its voting
population but it's still the case that
on average of course you know they have
say democratic states is going to be
more extreme in terms of the voters
there it's also the case that
when you have a safe democratic seat uh
in terms of campaign finance there are
going to be more demand for
outside uh money there and it is
interesting because sometimes we don't
really
kind of consider that you have a safe
democratic seas actually it still
requires a lot of
you know funds and money to actually
campaign in those places but it is the
case that in those places we see
more reliance on interest groups and
kind of outside
uh money in terms of you know out of
district spending as well
but most importantly for our purposes
here i would like to emphasize that in
safer
seats whether it's democratic or
republican seats we have more
vulnerability to more
uh primary challengers and also more
extreme primary challenges and i just
wanted to show you like a few graphs
that can be
relevant to what we're talking about
here right so
first if we just consider the universe
of
primary challengers and you know the
incumbents who have to face these
challenges we see that
the primary challenges are usually more
ideologically in stream as measured as
cf scores here which
is based on campaign finance networks so
what we see
here is basically when we look at
challengers that are um
blue dots here they're on average you
know a higher
and there's violent plots which means
they have kind of more conservative
quote-unquote ideology compared to the
incumbents in those districts
and we see that kind of opposite picture
for that for democrats that we see that
if we look at democratic challengers in
safe receipts
or more generally they're usually more
extreme than those
that are open incumbents and but most
importantly
for our purposes we also see that if you
are in a safe seat
which is measured by this uh cook
partisan voting
except that kiel is going to talk a
little bit more about later
we see that you know uh representatives
uh
and incumbents in those districts are
more likely to face primary
challenge and actually even more so the
case in republican safe seats
another uh kind of part of the puzzle
which is important for our story here
which is another part of the
paper is that we see a gradual decline
in electoral competition
uh for u.s house
across years so you know obviously we
have redistricting we have
uh sort of like oscillations here and
there but in general the trend is on
decline
so this is just uh you know um uh
safety based on you know basic margin of
victory but we can also see the same
story when it comes to kind of
ex-ante measure of competitiveness based
on this uh partisan voting index
where we see that there is a decline has
been a decline of marginal receipts
since 1992
since you know when we had the data and
we also have a slight increase
of democratic and especially the
republican safe seats
okay okay i think i can go back to you
now thank you
sorry um so yeah so connecting the story
of safe seats and extremism back to our
original theory
what we posit then is that democratic
women should perform better in safe
democratic seats
whereas republican women should be
dramatically outperformed in safe
republican seats
and so to to really study this problem
in a more rigorous way
we combined two existing data sets and
append some
metrics uh that we think are lacking in
them so far
so first we start with adam monica's
2019 database of ideology and money in
elections
to identify all of the candidates who
have filed with the fec
to run for congress and some basic
demographic information of them
both on the campaign finance side and
also personal demographic information
like gender
and the nice thing about this data set
is we also get a sense of their actual
electoral fortunes
then we take a data set from cook
political
to look at the cook pvi which is a
measure of the partisan composition and
electoral competitiveness
of house districts so the way to think
of a cooked pvi
is as a relative measure so if we say
a district is democrat plus five that
means in a year were democrats and
republicans
tied overall across the nation we would
expect that district to voted five
points more for the democratic candidate
than the republican candidate
and the first thing that we try to do is
just a pretty basic descriptive task
uh so right here what we see is the
modeled win probability
for uh the democratic and republican
candidates
uh by their seat safety and by gender
so just to walk us through this really
quickly the top panels are all
republicans and what we see here is that
looking at the leftmost panel which is
the overall win rate
for the vast majority of seats you see
almost gender parity
in that the probability that a woman or
a man who enters
the primary election has virtually the
same probability of winning the election
now
i should caution that these are probably
conservative estimates of gender bias
because as anzio and barry have very
famously
shown women candidates who actually
enter elections
are often of higher quality than their
male counterparts
but the important takeaway here is that
even though you have gender parity for
the vast majority of seeds
you see divergence among these very safe
seats
uh on the right and you might think well
how many seats can it be
that are more than r plus 20 how big of
a problem this is
actually it's a fairly substantial
problem in this current
congress about a fourth of all seats are
in that range where we see that
divergence
on the republican side and on the
democrats democratic side you also see
a slightly stark pattern in the opposite
direction which is that in the safe
democratic seats
women are advantaged in their overall
likelihood of winning
again this is conditional on them
entering the primary which suggests they
may be of higher quality
than their male challengers but as you
get into more competitive seats you see
that advantage fade away and you
actually see some evidence of a
disadvantage
this is all to say that from a purely
descriptive account
it does seem as though women candidates
are
advantaged in the democratic side in
safer seats and disadvantaged on the
republican side in safer seats
and that gender gap we showed does seem
to originate partially in safer seats
but when we add slightly more rigorous
methods and control
for other potentially confounding
variables does this relationship still
hold up
our answer at least as far as we've
tested it seems to be
yes that as you get more extreme
seats the the relationship
right here this our our fourth variable
that we have listed
um female times pvi that's the
interaction effect between
your seat getting safer in the
conservative direction
and a woman candidate so these estimates
would suggest
in very liberal seats you should see
which would have negative pvis
you'd see an advantage to being a woman
versus in very conservative seats you
would see a stark disadvantage
which supports the descriptive finding
that we had
in the last slide
and so now we want to return back to one
of the uh
important alternative uh hypotheses that
we presented at the beginning that the
conventional explanation literature
holds which is that
you know part of this reason that you
see that stark relationship between seat
safety
uh and and women candidates could be
candidate supply
and we do find actually evidence that
candidates supply starkly differs
between democrats and republicans
but what's important to us is we also
see that that relationship
differs in terms of seat safety that yes
you have that overall decline
that overall partisan gap excuse me in
women who run
but as seats trend towards safer
republican seats
less and less women are running for
congress which suggests that this safe
seat explanation
cannot be explained simply by the
overall raw partisan gender gap
itself and because of that we think that
this is an important domain for future
research and an important way of
understanding
why we've gotten to a point where the
dynamics of congress are such that
you know women democrats are are on the
rise but women republicans have seen
pretty anemic growth
uh since the the uh since the 1980s
um and one thing that i just want to
mention before we move on to the
discussion
is a potential challenge for our case
one would think
could be this most recent set of
elections 2020
of course famously in 2020 almost every
single republican who defeated an
incumbent democrat
was a woman or a candidate of color but
actually when we go through and look at
the
the evidence we do see further evidence
for our theory in that it was only in
these competitive seats
that the republican women were able to
win and actually they made very little
headway
in the much safer seats um and so
finally i just want to end with a couple
of questions that we want to pose out
into the ether
so the first is how should we think
about nonpartisan democratic aims in the
context of redistricting
oftentimes the discourse on
gerrymandering is talking about partisan
gerrymandering
and goes to this question of substantive
representation as pitkin would put it
but what we're really talking about is
descriptive representation and we think
that
in line with these findings there are
also important descriptive consequences
of safe seats through things like
majority minority districts
it's important to think about these
non-partisan democratic aims
when we're considering something as
partisan as redistricting
our second question is what we've
presented here today has been
um entirely observational evidence
so one of the questions that we have
going forward are are there ways to
gather more experimental or
quasi-experimental evidence on this
phenomenon
and in terms of future research just to
set that up one of the outstanding
questions is
how do the few women who do win in these
safe republican seats respond to these
pressures
and we're thinking of recent examples of
people like marjorie taylor green
for example and that brings us to the
end
of our prepared presentation
okay all right thanks very much
for the invitation to comment on this
terrific paper
uh this paper examines one of the most
uh salient and interesting
changes in congress over recent decades
and that is the
divergence in the gender composition of
the two parties
before 1990 women were slowly increasing
their presence in both
congressional parties but after 1990 the
two parties diverged
after the so-called year of the woman in
1992
women steadily and sharply increased as
a share of the democratic party in
congress
by contrast republicans stopped becoming
more gender diverse for 20 years after
2004.
the first significant increase in
republican women just
happened with the 2020 elections a 75
percent jump over the preceding congress
so
2020 was unquestionably the year of the
republican woman
but even after the 2020 boost for
republicans the gender discrepancy
between the parties is still wide
nearly 40 percent of congressional
democrats are women
as compared to 14 percent of
congressional republicans
this remarkable partisan divergence in
women's representation is just
one among other forms of sociological
divergence
between the parties just for perspective
i'll highlight a couple of
other cases of social sorting in
congress
religion i'll focus on evangelical
christians the largest religious
group in the u.s constituting just over
a quarter of the population
in the late 1970s evangelicals made up
roughly the same share of both
congressional parties
but since the 80s evangelicals have
steadily sorted out of the democratic
party and into the republican party
in recent congresses evangelicals make
up more than one-third of republicans
but less than five percent of democrats
race another form of social sorting as
the u.s population has become more
racially diverse
since the 1960s virtually all of that
diversity
is representing the democratic party in
congress the democratic party in
congress has grown steadily more
racially and ethnically diverse since
the 1970s such that 40 percent of the
party in congress is currently black
hispanic or asian
meanwhile the nation's increasing
diversity is just passing the republican
party by
non-whites have never made up more than
seven percent of republicans in congress
so the parties have been sorting out in
sociological terms
the parties are not just polarized
ideologically
they are also strongly differentiated in
terms of personal identity
the paper we're discussing today helps
give us some new perspective
on factors that are driving these
changes in congressional composition
the paper argues that increases in the
number of saved seats affect the two
parties differently
women candidates are more competitive
for safe democratic party seats
but less competitive for safe republican
seats
thus the rise in safe seats can help
shed some light on what's happening in
both parties
the processes laid out in this paper
involve multiple steps
the paper theorizes that see seat safety
affects the decision to run who wins in
primaries
and who wins in the general election
seat safety is thought to affect each of
these steps in the process
as the as the authors continue to work
on this paper i'd like to see a more
careful breakdown
of each step ideally the paper would
nail down the
extent to which each of these factors
contributes to the overall pattern
it would be great to see the descriptive
statistics
you know even without any controls as a
first order matter
what is the difference between safe
republican districts
and those that are marginal for
republicans in terms of the number of
women running in the primaries
the likelihood that a woman wins the
primary the likelihood that a woman wins
a general election
and what are the differences between
safe democratic districts
and those that are marginal for
democrats on those dimensions and what
are the effect sizes at each step
my key recommendation is that
i think it'd be useful to model the two
parties separately
the party works with one overall model
assuming that seat safety
affects female candidates in both
parties in ways that can be handled with
simple interaction effects but there are
reasons to think that the effects of
safe seats on candidacy may differ for
the two parties
i can think of three ways in which
gender might affect congressional
elections and candidacy
first and this is the one that's covered
in most depth in the paper
women are perceived as more liberal
which is a disadvantage in safe
republican districts and an advantage in
safe democratic districts
the the paper substantially elaborates
on that
there are other reasons beyond voter
perceptions
to expect that safe seats will affect
gender representation
there's perception and then there's
reality women actually are more liberal
even among republicans such that there
is a smaller pool of potential female
republicans
considering a run for office in
conservative districts
this is something danielle thompson
finds in her research on state
legislatures
in an article published in legislative
studies quarterly in 2015
thompson finds that there's a dearth of
very conservative women
suitable to make a competitive bid for
congress
in those strongly republican districts
she suggests that the pool of very
conservative women may be growing
but it was still small as part of as of
her study in 2015.
there simply weren't many quality
republican women candidates available to
run
in conservative districts meaning
conservative women who had won
elected office at some level before but
the same pattern doesn't exist for
the democratic party thompson finds that
there's a substantial pool of moderate
women
available in state legislatures able to
make a bid for congress so there's no
shortage of democratic women available
to run in both moderate
and liberal districts
third potential women candidates may
have a differential willingness to run
in the two parties women may look at the
republican party in congress and see
themselves
not fitting in after all it's an
overwhelmingly male dominated party
women may not look at the congressional
gop and see a caucus
in which they feel likely that they'll
be able to advance
their personal and policy goals but
women probably don't look at the
democratic party similarly
they're likely to perceive the
congressional democratic caucus as one
where they might fit in
and be able to advance their personal uh
next the safe seats logic laid out in
the paper works somewhat differently for
the two parties
democratic party is reasonably friendly
to women candidates across the board
meanwhile republicans republican women
probably face a tougher road
where they are more disadvantaged in
conservative districts
the democratic women are disadvantaged
in swing districts
if these kinds of asymmetries exist the
model used in the paper
which includes candidates of both
parties will likely understate the
gender effect for republicans
and overstate the gender effect for
democrats
so i'd like to see a separate model for
but for the two parties and does seat
safety have a significant effect on
women's
candidacies for both parties
second point i'd like to make is just a
note of caution
i really think the authors are on to
something here with this argument about
how safe seats affect
gender representation but it's important
to note that there's a limit to how much
this logic can explain
no doubt there's been a major change in
congressional elections there are far
more seat safe seats today than there
were in the late 19th and early 20th
centuries
uh so here's a figure from uh from other
work by the authors
as is evident here it used to be that
more than 40 percent of house districts
had elections decided in the marginal
range
and now it's around 10 percent but most
of that change happened a long time ago
david mayhew published his famous paper
on the vanishing marginals in 1974.
there has been continued decline in
almost 50 years since
but the post-1974 change is less
than the change that occurred in the 50
years before
1974. meanwhile recall that the gender
sorting of the parties only got away got
underway after 1990. before 1990 the
share of women in the two congressional
parties was low
but growing in tandem it's only after
1990 that we see the divergence this
paper aims to explain
the share in this the change in the
share
of safe seats since 1992 is just a few
percentage points
so it's not a dramatic drop since the
90s
given that seat safety hasn't changed a
lot in recent years safe seats can only
explain
part of the gender sorting that we've
seen since 1990.
now i'm persuaded that the authors are
really onto something here i suspect
that the analysis will hold up to
further robustness checks
including as i recommend splitting the
data by party
but clearly there's much more to learn
about what's driving
congressional parties apart along lines
of gender and other sociological factors
before i conclude i'd like to make one
final small point
the paper often implies that the decline
of competition
in congressional races stems from
partisan gerrymandering
this linkage is often suggested in the
popular press
but political scientists working on this
subject have not been able to document
a an effect along these lines
here's a representative finding in the
literature from a 2006
jop paper by abramowitz alexander and
gunning
a paper that's cited in
uh in the paper we're discussing um uh
abramowitz and his co-authors look at
the number of safe and competitive house
seats before and after three recent
rounds of redistricting so you can see
from the
in 1980 and then the number of safe
seats
in 1982 the number of safe and
competitive seats in 1990 and then after
the redistricting in 1992 and so forth
and they find that redistricting does
not substantially increase the share of
safe and competitive seats and they
conclude that
at the national level redistricting has
a negligible impact
on the competitiveness of house seats
the reason why partisan gerrymandering
does not
have a you know consistent effect on
electoral competition is that partisan
the goal of partisan gerrymandering is
not
to maximize seat safety the goal of
partisan gerrymandering is to maximize
the number of winnable seats for a party
effective gerrymandering cannot pack too
many
of a party's voters into a single
district
if it wants to win as many seats as
possible gerrymanderers will often have
to go
to their own party's incumbents to get
them to agree
to reduce their cushion of support so as
to spread out more of their party's
voters into neighboring seats
the goal of gerrymandering is to make as
many winnable seats as possible but
doing so will tend to depress a party's
margin of victory
in those districts now of course it's
also true that partisan gerrymanderers
may aim to pack
the opposing party's voters into as few
seats as possible
and doing this obviously makes for some
very safe seats like the overwhelmingly
democratic majority minority districts
but gerrymanderers also try to crack
opposing party voters across a lot of
seats so that the opposing party doesn't
have a very good shot at winning any of
them
the bottom line is that taken together
gerrymandering makes some seats safer
and other seats more competitive the
overall effect of
gerrymandering on competition just tends
to wash out
the rise of seat safety in congress has
other causes
aside from partisan gerrymandering this
is not a critical point for this paper
given that the paper isn't even about
the causes of safe seats anyway
but just uh steer the authors away from
unnecessary controversy uh
in the write-up so i'll stop there
i think that's probably can everyone see
that okay
i don't i only have only have two slides
and one of them is actually from the uh
from the authors
uh well i'll start off by just saying
thank you and i really enjoyed this
opportunity i enjoyed reading the paper
i think it's a great topic
it's uh it's a really uh it's a it's a
really useful data uh
exercise and they're just some really
interesting stylized facts that are
starting to emerge
i think the first time i read through
the paper i was i i
felt you know like i was kind of
convinced by what the authors were
saying and uh
wasn't sure what i would have to say but
then on looking at it more carefully
uh i started to have a lot more
questions and uh and some of them are
about the theory and some of them are
about the empirics
and uh i'll kind of i'll dive into both
of those um
the first thing i want to do is just uh
is just to say a little bit about
the ways of framing the paper i mean
obviously there's a lot
um there's a you have some some some
folks among you
among the authors who know a lot about
the cross-national literature
on gender and representation and uh and
maybe maybe linking this in with a
larger literature on on gender and
why the u.s perhaps is a is a does this
paper
help us understand why the u.s is an
outlier relative to other countries
might be an interesting framing device
to consider but also
um in the u.s literature one paper i
wanted to direct your attention to is by
a former student of mine sarah anzia has
a paper
with using a really large data set from
california in which she finds kind of
surprising evidence of an advantage for
female candidates in a lot of local
offices
and finds that the um that there's
something about the nature of those
offices that the advantage is large is
for school board races and it gets a
little smaller for
city council races and a little smaller
for mayoral elections
but you also find some evidence that's
consistent with yours it says that this
this basically disappears this this
female advantage disappears
the more conservative the districts
become which is perhaps not
too surprising um i also think there's a
related literature on local governments
in the us it might be nice to also think
about that where the the story
is that um one emerging story and it's
one that i've i've seen and some data
i've looked at
is that when we look at at-large
districts versus uh
when the same people are represented in
at-large districts versus
uh single-member district elections the
um the at-large districts are better
are better for female recruitment we end
up with more female candidates running
and more female candidates winning
and that probably has something to do
with comp competition competitiveness
in um you know in winner-take-all
municipal uh
city council elections are often very
uncompetitive and there are
long-standing incumbents hanging around
uh who are these these are people who a
a female candidate might might be less
inclined to
to to jump in and try to challenge than
um maybe a say a seven-member school
board that has three seats up
three at large seats up two of which
might be open seats
effectively uh that's a very different
kind of setting so this this
this kind of literature i think is very
related to what you're doing in the
congressional context
and uh and i would but i would also
encourage you to think you know you've
got several authors and hopefully a lot
of time on your hands maybe uh
it would be a very small lift to add
state legislators to this study
this carl kleiner data set on um on
state legislatures could be linked with
the dime data and you could be up and
running doing some similar kind of
analysis
with state legislatures and that would
just give you a larger sample and some
some interesting cross state
heterogeneity and all of that
uh so uh that would be a nice thing to
to think about doing
um so one thing that i thought um
i thought francis might get into i'm so
she definitely checked the box on the
gerrymandering so everything she said
about gerrymandering i
agree with i think it's good it's good
to have you know when when people
two people have the same reaction it's
good to know what that is i don't i
don't think this is a paper about
gerrymandering per se it's a paper about
safe seats and so
you don't need to make those arguments
about gerrymandering um but um
i something that i thought might come up
is just a i was surprised not to see
incumbency
at least among the control variables uh
even even even
more i thought it might make sense as a
as something to explore heterogeneous
effects you know are we talking about
what happens when we look at open seats
versus seats where there are
long-standing incumbents you know i i
think that um uh
incumbency of course is is highly
correlated with uh
with the safety of the seats and a lot
of those safe seats are going to be ones
when there is an incumbent a
long-standing incumbent running and some
of the people in your data set you're
looking at some of these challengers are
going to be not particularly serious
challengers because it's someone who
everyone knows is going to win
both the primary and the general um and
then there are
um situations though even in a very
even in a very safe seat where a
long-standing incumbent uh
steps down and then there's an open seat
i just
surely the dynamics are different in
those and so it would be it'd be useful
to
to take a look at those separately
um i also want to think about maybe uh
uh of course you know you i have to say
something about political geography and
and think about how that might matter um
it one possible alternative hypothesis
is you know if you just look at the
correlation between the between the cook
index and population density the
correlation is like you know
it's like 0.9 or something it's very
high um
uh this this this thing that you know
the main independent variable here or
the interaction term
is is very much correlated with uh with
uh geography in a particular way
so that the safe seats are essentially
state republican seats are very rural
safe uh safe democratic seats are almost
always urban with a couple of exceptions
in the deep south and um
majority minority districts there but
for the most part these competitive
districts are going to be suburban
districts
and uh and as as one of you kind of
mentioned some of those
suburban districts and some of these you
know 50 50 districts can actually end up
being internally quite polarized they
can be
if you look at people's preferences
within the districts you end up with
this kind of bimodal distribution
of of of political preferences and so i
would kind of come back to that that
thought
in in a moment um but um but but what
this
and i just want to get i actually want
to hear back from the authors
just how they see the argument working
because the story they want to tell
as i understand the paper and the
presentation is that it's about
perceptions of candidates platforms that
people
in a sense misperceive uh that they
believe the female candidates to be
more cons to more be more liberal than
they might actually
be so there's some kind of a penalty
that
applies to a female candidate who's
trying to run in a conservative district
where she has to really try
hard she has to kind of do some things
to signal that she really is
conservative because
gender is a cue that people are using
and so that's that i understand to be
the mechanism
that it's about perception of the
candidate but there's this alternative
mechanism which is just that
um over time democrats have become more
progressive on
gender issues in general and that
something
about that is highly correlated with
their ability their desire to or their
you know their bias against
female candidates and so that over time
democratic voters
in the democratic districts have become
less
biased against female candidates but in
these relatively rural districts
where people are more traditional on
economic issues
and and social issues i mean
particularly what we care about here is
social issues and gender issues
that in those places um people uh that
things haven't really changed and that
accounts for the for the different
trajectories
not really this perception issue and so
i would encourage you to think about
empirically how can we disentangle these
things these different
possible mechanisms and one way might be
if you go in the cces
there are questions in there that ask
respondents what they think
the candidates platforms are on a seven
point scale and on some different policy
issues
so can you kind of show what you believe
to be going is going on that that people
are
misperceiving or they're somehow uh
overestimating
the um the uh the the the uh
kind of leftist orientation of women
even in the republican party
something like that um um but so
i guess one of the things i really want
to talk about though is that as you were
doing the presentation as because you
handed it off from alex to
heal i felt like there was something
important in the in the in the
theoretical argument that was missing i
didn't quite understand and also when i
read the paper
what is it about seat safety and the
cook index
that you really think matters um uh
it's it's this idea again it's about
potential misperception of
female candidates ideology but i i want
to understand and i think you probably
do have
a logic here that makes sense but i just
it's not spelled out as
as crisply as i'd like what is it that's
different about a safe seat district
than a than a competitive district
or in my language what is it that's
different about a rural district the
suburban district
um and i think what you're saying is
that the primary electorate
is different in some important way but
what exactly is it
that is different about the primary
electorate in the rural district is it
just the number is it like a i think it
might help that little
a little toy formal model here whether
it's something like uh ideological cut
point
and then there's this misperception like
is the misperception
larger in those places is like it harder
to credibly commit as a female to have
to could kind of be closer to the
ideological platform preferred by the
medium voter
is it kind of that kind of a commitment
problem that's larger or is it just like
the number of voters who are past some
threshold is larger
it wasn't clear to me exactly how that
argument worked
um um that could have been clear
okay so on the on the empirics um
um i agree with a lot uh i just again
it's kind of helpful to know that two
people have the same reaction i agreed
that it would be nice to just see the
data just to see
to kind of cascade down from the the
question of who
who runs in the primary who wins in the
primary and then who wins in the general
i have exactly that same thing in my
notes but you want to go through that
you want to show us the uh just the raw
descriptive statistics
that would be great um um but one thing
i i just wanted to talk about though
that i'm confused by and i hope you can
help me with is what's going on in
figure two
because um uh when you went through it
in the presentation
we just talked about the left hand panel
and we talked that essentially
all the emphasis is on that gap on the
upper left hand panel here between that
dotted line
or the dashed line and the solid line um
but in the paper we are told that it's
really that
there's this big difference between
primary elections
between safe seats and uh
and competitive seats for republican
women in primary elections
when i look at that middle uh that
middle panel i just don't see it i see a
couple of lines that are right on top of
each other and i see confidence
intervals that suggest to me
that there's absolutely no difference at
any level
of of competitiveness between a woman's
win probability and a man's wing
probability in the
republican primary and when i go to the
right hand panel i look at the general
election i also don't see
any difference i see something strange
happening where the
the stata has apparently uh not wanted
to finish the
local polynomial as we move to the right
past like 20
something for uh for females and so
maybe there's a big gap there but we're
not seeing it
because i just don't understand how we
get to the overall gap when we don't see
the gap in the primaries because the
story in
in in table a2 is that there's a three
percentage point difference for females
throughout the whole range and it gets
even bigger
as we get into these safe seats so it's
not showing up in these local polynomial
plots and i guess my big question is why
um and like i almost don't think figure
2
and table a2 can both be correct
um i so so i just want to know what's
happening there
but i certainly do see um i i do see a
big uh
an interesting effect here for um for
democratic
on the democratic side between between
uh men and women
so um um i think i'm probably running
short on time i should probably just
wrap it up here
um uh but i i think that the the big
findings for me is you know i i'd like
to know
um whether this you know whether this
safe seat thing for the republicans
is is going to hold up and how big it is
but there's i'm certainly looks like
there's something there for the for the
democrats
um but it also looks like you know you
have some really powerful evidence that
there's just a big difference
in uh in who and who runs
that at the end of the day that that's
one of the things that really hit me
between the eyes that there is a big
difference
in um in in just a candidate recruitment
and um uh and that those kind of those
things are kind of working together
this effect for for democrats in safe
seats which seems to be very
very large uh and and um i'm not sure
whether this the one on the republican
side if you could just help me with
figure
two um um but uh the really big thing is
is the
is just the difference in in and who
runs in what
and what i'm looking at here
um all right i think plenty plenty for
us to talk about there so i'll turn it
back thank you so much
jonathan um so i given the time i just
want to know
uh do the the uh author presenters
uh wanna make like one or two quick
remarks and then we can go to questions
if if the audience has questions you can
also
pass if you want to pass it's totally
it's a it's totally your
your call i think these were you know
really fantastic and thought provoking
discussions
and that you could easily spend an hour
i think on francis's remarks and on
jonathan's
but we don't have an hour uh please go
ahead
yeah i agree with that so i'm i'm
inclined to
to pass and if people and alex want to
uh respond is that okay alex and uh
that we go to the questions but thumbs
up excellent okay
ian take it away uh i think you have a
question or um hands raised
uh you're you're in you're you're in
control
okay i'm not seeing any hand raise but i
am seeing a question in the chat which
says republican states are generally
seen as having strong
christian views whereas democratic ones
are a bit liberal in terms of christian
views
do you think this approach does shape
the opportunity given to women
politically
given that christianity generally frowns
on women taking leadership positions in
society
anyone wondering
i think in general if i may just say a
few words i think it kind of taps into
some of the comments uh brought up by
odysseus which were excellent by the way
and
we you know really take everything
really well especially you know the
gerrymandering comment i think that's
we should really turn it down because i
don't think we believe that
gerrymandering is the key here
uh but when it comes to crescendo i
think it's the same question as some of
you had us whether
we're talking about perceptions uh
related to gender or the reality that
a woman candidate can actually be more
liberal on average than men
i think for our story it's not
necessarily the case that we only care
about perception can be both
actually and the fact that it turns out
that in safer
republican seats you have rural
populations more traditional gender
views
and you know it just disadvantages women
in general who want to
kind of you know run for office in this
district i don't necessarily
think that it's not in line with our
ethereum it's just some kind of
alternative expression i think it's
pretty much in line with what we're
trying to say but i totally agree that
you know we have to be clear about
what's so special about
safe seats uh relative to like a toss-up
um i was going to say if while you're
waiting for
hands to go up or questions to be asked
you should certainly feel free
in the gaps to respond to francis
or jonathan if you would if you would
like um
so one thing um kill
i don't know if you wanted to pick up on
this but on francis's point that
um the the rise of safe seats has been
going on for a long time and
in the period we're talking about it it
hasn't been
that much of an increase um that's
that's true obviously on one hand but on
the other hand
we do have data about the partisan
difference in the growth of say seats in
recent decades
so uh do you have any comments on
on that as a response to how much
of the heavy lifting the uh safe seats
can do
yeah i actually wanted to say a few
words but i think i kill might be useful
if you can
say a few words about figure two and its
discrepancy with the regression table
since you
uh worked on it more uh but so with
regard to the evidence on safe seats so
i think it's true that if you look just
uh at the measure of margin of
victory you don't really see a lot of
difference in the last 20 or 30 years
but i think this measure in general is
very kind of
not very robust right that's why i feel
comfortable plotting it starting
right after civil war and these in
general you see this kind of downward
trend but i think
if you kind of want to zoom in and look
at the trajectory within 20 or 30 years
i think it's
not as easy to do that because of you
know different
uh the redistricting and other also
changes that have
cured i think that's why i think the
cook partisan voting index is more
robust
as a measure of ex-anti-competitiveness
right so where we
look at the partisan composition and the
two elections prior relative to the
uh you know nation in general i think if
you look at the coup partisan voting
index
and the trajectory in the last 30 years
starting in 1990 we actually have this
evidence that
safe seats have been on decrease right
uh pretty you know steadily right it's
not a huge
change and with unfortunately we don't
really have a lot of i think it's
possible to construct it but we don't
really have this data at hand
we've got to ai prior to nine tonight
but i believe
if we did have it probably would see
that it's been you know in decline since
before that as well
okay before akiel takes up jonathan's
question about figure 2
um i see we do have a question from gail
so i just joined your session a little
bit late but
um my question is because this is a
discussion has er revolved around women
um seeking candidacy
candidacy and safe seats i just wanted
to get your impression on
the republican party's attempt to
attempt on voter suppression
um and gerrymandering what
impact do you think this will have on
the potential for women
running for congressional offices
so while you think about that why don't
we get that cna's question as well
hello can you hear me uh hi
so i'm new to all of this and i'm just a
high school senior
and i'm not even sure if i'm
understanding all of this right
but
hello now you come back yeah hi
so i'm wondering if the person who is
responsible for gerrymandering
is the state legislatures and that means
that
they are allowed to increase or decrease
safe seats
and competitive seats in like a district
does that mean
that state legislatures in theory
can manipulate like female
representative
in an area
yeah that's my question thank you
yeah thank you i think presumably in
theory and that's i think that's one
actually just look at the paper and i
think that's one of the
we use the word general mandarin twice
in the paper and i think that's one of
the kind of policies suggestions that we
have and that's that's what discussions
we're not really happy about
so i don't i don't think that so in
theory it's possible but i think in
practice uh you know due to kind of
partisan sorting more generally that
people just tend to leave with someone
who is so similar to the ideology
whether you know uh
deliberately or not it happens that you
know republicans live in rural areas
with other republicans and democrats
live in
urban areas with other uh democrats so
you know the extent to which you can
kind of manufacture uh you know safe
seats with gerrymandering i think is
very limited but
you can imagine how it is possible and
then thereby affect
you know the proportion of female
representation but i i don't think
that's a big concern and i think the
same kind of
answer i would have with regard to voter
suppression which is you know a very
important issue but i'm not sure how
exactly would play out with regard to
the gender dynamic if any of my
uh colleagues would like to add on that
i would be great
i would just i would just add um that
whatever the causes of safe seats are
to what extent it's self-sorting what it
sent
its demography to what extent it's
gerrymandering and to what extent it's
things like majority minority districts
i don't think
to the extent there's any agency
involved human agency and planning
i don't think anybody was intending it
to reduce female representation the
republican side relative to the
democratic side i think it's an
unintended side effect of whatever has
been done by people as my guess
yeah and just to jump in there because i
think
again taking the the comments from our
two discussants very seriously
i think there is a question at least for
me which is that when we look at things
like majority minority districts we do
see examples of
intentional uh map manipulation
if you want to call it that to advance
descriptive representation so i think
one of the points that we were trying to
make
um with our references to gerrymandering
which noted uh should be taken out is
not necessarily that that is the cause
right now but that could be
a prerogative that gerrymanders think
about or people drawing the lines
and i think about this in the context of
for example the aclu right now when
they're looking at redistricting for the
next year
they're looking at racial redistricting
for example
we don't have a similar concept for
gender redistricting
but perhaps that's something that in the
back of our minds we should keep in mind
these unintentional question
consequences that professor shapiro was
talking about
okay um i see that we're coming up to
815 which is um
uh when we're when we're scheduled to
finish
um i just want to ask first the um the
discussions are there any uh
last comments you'd like to make and
then i'll turn to the
panelists and ask if there are any last
comments that any of the panelists
who are presenting their work would like
to make
not for me okay thank you francis
just keep up the good work i look
forward to seeing the next draft of this
terrific thank you jonathan um and our
our panelist authors is there anything
else you'd like to say before we
conclude
no thank you for having us it's a
pleasure absolute pleasure
um well let me say um francis and
jonathan
you are welcome at any time you want to
drop in here to yale
um and it reminds us just how wonderful
our colleagues are
out there in the big world um and uh and
thank you for
such thoughtful contributions to the
discussion
and of course thank you to the authors
for
this you know illuminating and
stimulating a paper this is a dimension
to safe seats that i think no one
contemplated
and it will definitely affect the way i
i look at
the patterns of congressional
competition moving forward so again
thank you all so much with that um
let me say uh thank you very much
everyone for attending
our next isps democracy event is on
tuesday april 13th at 4 p.m
where we'll have a panel to discuss
novel ideas for
elections and legislative decision
making
and please look for future isps events
at our isps website i'd also like to
conclude by thanking all of the people
who worked so hard to put this event
together
the organizers of this panel they
include pam greene
pamela monica torrey bilsky and the more
peer
with that again thank you all for
participating and attending tonight
and i look forward to seeing you at
future events good night
good night